Wendy welcome to the podcast hey lovely
to be here as I was as I was saying to
you before we started this first I first
heard you speak when uh yeah I booked
myself a ticket to a UK recruitment
event on my own when I worked in
recruitment um have always seen you
speaking at recruitment Expo always seen
you in the red of fire fish definitely
uh so uh now we're here so I'm really
looking forward to do a few things here
one actually unpack a bit of your
entrepreneurial Journey cuz I think
you've been on a really interesting
Journey from starting your own
recruitment business to then uh turning
a product that you you know wanted for
yourself into uh a business that has now
been going for over a decade uh and also
talking about this recent investment
journey I think people always interested
in that cuz I know when you release that
video of we've we we're announcing this
round how much hard work goes into
leading up to that and it isn't as
straightforward as people think and also
yeah like where where fire fish is going
and what you're staying true to in terms
of yeah like what you're staying true to
to serve your community um and what you
really believe in so a lot to uncover
that's I'm looking forward to as long as
you don't make me feel
old I'll try my best um but why don't we
just start with so feel free to cor if
I'm wrong but from what I saw on
LinkedIn you basically started your own
recruitment business
and I think at the peak you put on
LinkedIn that around 15 16 people
generating just over 1 and a half
million in Revenue um and then did you
exit that business yeah yeah so you
exited that and then the reason why you
exited that was you wanted to go on this
journey with fiveish is that right yeah
it's a bit of both so um I suppose just
prior to that you know I was the usual
way you fall into recruitment top biller
um and then fell in decided I was going
to do it myself um and and you know
first year managed to turn over a
hundred you know turn over the first
million from a back Bedroom Story
scenario as well with my first employee
and I exited with my first employee
doing a management investment L
management buyout so that was a really
nice story but you're absolutely correct
the drive for me to leave that business
was really um I'd always wanted to run a
tech business um but my heart was in
recruitment so be able to combining both
of them and it fell off of of a real
frustration when I was running my own
recruitment business for the tech that
was out there you know it it just got um
at that time which was around 2004 2005
or something um you know really you had
rdb you had bond that was about it you
know bullhorn was maybe coming onto the
marketplace and I could see from being a
tech recruiter what was really happening
out there in terms of the technology
consumer-led technology inbound
marketing all this cool stuff that could
happen from the web coming into your
database and recruitment was so behind
so I went screw this I'm going to build
this um and we decided to start building
this for um my my own business so we
spent four years really there developing
that before we decided let's spin it out
so so in those four years what was it
even called Firefish then or not so we
had a name um and people say why
Firefish Etc and there's no clever story
to that um basically the designer
upstairs gave me an option of pumpkin or
far fish and I decided pumpkin was a bit
know so and Farish had leg or had fins
as we say so that was that was good so
it was just getting born with that name
but we spun it out from the recruitment
to have two separate entities um and
that's really where um you know I was
running both um it was also as any of
your um uh listeners out there probably
entrepreneur as well it was 2010 that it
was born so we were in the middle of the
recession it was really boring doing
recruitment so I needed more things to
do I also had a child at that point too
which was nuts so
what happening so yeah I I really
resonate with building something around
a problem that you have um I really
resonate with that cuz that's sort of
what has really spurred on my own
entrepreneurial journey and I think it's
such a great like foundation and
platform to start from in terms of
whatever it is you're building in your
business you're trying to solve at the
center of that you're trying to solve a
problem that you've experienced
firsthand cuz I think that gives you
such an upper hand when it comes to to
really understanding where your offering
and and service needs to go or what you
need to stay true to CU you really
understand those problems so just
curious then if I can cast you back to
that early period what were like the
core problems and the core frustrations
that you like this there has to be a
better way for this or like what were
the the core things that you first felt
like there has to be a better way yeah
so sorry to anybody that was using bond
out there now that they were taking over
I actually liked the bond culture of the
guys that were there at the start but
this was really what tipped me over the
edge because I was all about inbound
marketing with inbound marketing you
need to have your web connected to your
database so at that point I had to have
Bond net tools I had to specifically go
to one one particular web designer that
then had to integrate it all and every
day one of the components failed so I
wasn't getting the easiest thing for me
was getting an application through your
website into your database so that was
and every day I was on to their support
this I thought this must be better
because I could see that you know the no
longer cuz I was in tech as well that's
a little bit further and advanced in
some of the other professions that you
know CVS were not CVS or candidates were
not walking into the do you had to have
them on your web and drive that traffic
so this was a problem that nobody was
solving and nobody was thinking about a
database um that was actually alive and
breeding and able to get engagement and
able to get candidates converted
straight in so that's what we went out
to solve and the power of that in
re-engaging that candidate database is
you know I I know there are Critters out
there if you can get a candidate that
you place three or four time in that
career you know he's walking around with
a price tag in his head and you've just
made four placement fees out of that so
how do you keep and that's sweet isn't
it sweet placement dead easy you know
who you're selling you know they're good
and they come to you first there's no
competitiveness there so for me to be
able to re-engage that candidate and
keep tabs on that candidate I needed to
do that through the web the alerts and
seeing how that candidate was engaging
with my database you just can't you just
at that point were never able to do that
with all the databases that were out
there for recruiters they were like a
separate Administration database filing
cabinet that unless your recruiters made
a call or you said as a manager do your
admin at on Friday and update your kpis
it was just dead data that we were
putting into this big filing cabinet and
doing nothing with so that core problem
was yeah how can we make like all of
that just communicate with each each
other as smoly as possible which is
crazy to think
that I'm I'm assuming there's still
companies now that have some of those
issues to be fair do you know we're now
evolving and we'll get on to that in
terms of where our problem the problem
that we're now solving but um you know
the slide deck that I created and the
the original video to describe this
problem it still exists with companies
that are talking to us well I would
probably argue that although
Technologies come huge away um it's
almost overly complicated our world and
you've so many different things out
there that you know it's really hard to
actually get that true sort of core
vision of what's happening with your
candidate data um so unfortunately um
yeah there are still loads of companies
out there with that same problem um and
one to definitely you know we easily
solve and increase the number of
placements that they can get from their
existing
database so had a a bit of a internal
drive then to run a tech business which
is interesting um what were some of the
just curious like what were some of the
shifts you had to make as a founder of a
tech business compared to founded
recruitment business was there anything
that you particularly found challenging
or surprising about that shift or was a
lot of the things that you learned on
that recruitment entrepreneurial Journey
instantly you're able to transfer over
or is there anything that you're
surprised by yeah well I think you know
we live in a recruitment world where we
all just hire the same people that's the
first thing I've never been in an
industry that when you actually draw it
down go we all hire the same people um
so you know actually understanding how
to um how to work with different types
of people and different skill sets was
definitely something and they don't run
sometimes as fast as us recruiters I
think one of the things in terms of
comparison when you're running a
recruitment uh business um gosh the way
that you are able to learn how to manage
your money to go out and be sales Le um
to work hard in these ethics that is
phenomenal in the recruitment sector and
don't ever undervalue that within the
recruitment sector because in other
sectors like you know we are ahead I
think the problem is that we're almost
too ahead of that work ethos that
sometimes we don't work smartly enough
and that's what other sectors um have
brought and I've learned from running a
tech business that's interesting so what
were like been doing this for just over
I was looking like 14 years yeah such a
long time I was going to say you keep
going to say that the thing the thing
why I bring it up is because in my
journey so far which has only been two
three years I've already experienced
like feeling like my business is
entirely different but it's the same
like same business so I can only imagine
you know doing what you've been doing
for so long it's probably you probably
feel like it's had like different lives
and and different like felt almost
entirely different you probably feel
feel like you're going into a bit of a
different chapter now totally so I just
find that so interesting so like what
what did that initial like first chapter
look like you must have been really
excited you've you're solving a problem
that you really cared about you've
experienced firsthand you're selling to
people that you you were you were the
the person um that you were selling to
so like what what did you really Double
Down On In Those early earlier years
like how did it how did it initially
play out did you find yourselves really
supporting companies exactly like yours
or was it more people that are in that
you know one onean band or up to 10
people like what what how did you how
did it initially play out I'm just
curious yeah I mean I don't think it's
any secret we've we've become the um
sort of go-to for that 1 to 10 1 to 20
Market players and that's where we
definitely fit and actually to be honest
that really suited Us in the recruitment
world that's the largest sector it's top
billers um spinning out and wanting to
grow um so we we excelled in that and we
excelled in that because we just we
really really focused and doubled down
on that that sector and the reason why
we did that is that they it suited what
we were doing it was an all- inone
platform they got everything with the
one vendor so it simplified that like
top biller coming out and wanting to
grow and scale their business they got
their website they got their data base
they got the multi poster for one price
it was really you know it's it's a
really H good offering for that type of
person and then they grew um so that
that's that also helped because the life
cycle in terms of sales was you know 4
to 6 weeks and it converted and they
were paying me because I've done
everything organically and I think
that's um probably I didn't give myself
probably as much credit um as I now
which we'll get to in terms of the
investment Journey growing a SAS
business organically apparently is
unheard of so I needed money so that
market you know helped us to grow and
develop the product so that suited us um
and also at that point you know I was
just wanting to have fun um I loved
supporting companies that were doing
what I did um and you know we were able
to achieve a really good return for them
and investment so it suited both parties
and what did you I know you mentioned it
slightly there but like what did you
remain true to for that type of audience
like what is it that you felt like you
did a really good job of cuz I feel like
when you go down this path particularly
in like your world you can you tell me
but I feel like you could sometimes end
up getting all these different feedbacks
people saying we need this or we want
that this product needs to do that and
then you can find yourself maybe
creating things or going down on PA
going actually that isn't as
valuable as we thought it would be so
you mentioned a few things there but I
just interested like what what did you
find that for that particular Market
what is it that you really remain true
to that over this long period of time
they've actually genuinely really found
valuable in partnering with you guys
it's still one of our strengths today so
I just didn't let go of that connection
between why we started it up was that
connection between the web and the
database and having that as one product
so there was no integration there was no
points of failure and it was easy for
the recruiter none of none of my other
competitors were doing that and I know
it really annoyed a lot of them so that
also um suits me so what what does that
actually cuz I had a a demo of the
products and everything and went through
it so like from my understanding you
help me understand but like when you say
that because I feel like now Firefish
doesn't necessarily have to do your
front facing website but it can it can
enable that to happen just by um through
the job part but you you're going to be
better to explain it to me but when you
say that mean by that yeah so we're
evolving but if I go back to the earlier
days that's definitely where you know we
probably a lot of our other vendors and
partners would say that we were a bit
closed off and that wasn't us
deliberately saying we're not going to
be friends we were friends with all
everybody but we just didn't we just we
just had to put all of our internal
resources into building out the product
that our customers wanted and we
couldn't open the doors at that point
and and the web there allowed for almost
you know a total jobs or an S you know
all the um CV library or all that job
board functionality that we knew was
turning over loads of candidates and
recruiters were spending lots of money
we brought that into an asset for their
own recruitment company so when a
recruiter connects their
web um and then and instantly pass uh
posts a new vacancy were then alerting
all their candidate database right and
so you're not reliant on a recruiter
doing anything the recruiter used to
post a job and spend money on posting
jobs into the job boards and then
waiting for that would be the first
place they would go right that also was
a problem for the recruitment owner
because if they're paying for a CRM and
they're going out with the CRM straight
away before they even like created a job
that's you're not going to get a true
sense of what's happening in your
business so if you took that away and
the first place they did it is they
posted it in Farish and then it was
distributed out and then we gave them a
list of prospects of who's looking at it
who's reading it who's delivered it then
you're actually giving a list of
candidates to then go on target at the
right time as well because they've been
looking at your job and if you think
about that that could be somebody that
maybe you placed six months ago that
might not be happy so you need to go and
do that if that was in your retainer or
your um your rebate or it could be
somebody that was Contracting for you
that you never thought might look for a
permanent job or it could just be
somebody that you hadn't engaged with
and you thought was happy um and you
didn't have a call back scheduled for 12
months you know the number of times that
a recruitment owner would turn around
and say I'm so pissed off my recruiters
that company down the road that we had
the job on we had the candidate in our
database and they flipp and fed it that
is like 10K fee walking out the door and
it was on the database that doesn't
happen with Farish yeah no that that
makes complete sense in terms of why you
they remain true to that it was
completely unique as well at that time
but as we go and it's now thank you 14
years and we go into a different type of
world and and the you know the world of
recruitment is ever evolving and um our
positioning is evolving but we will
still remain very strong to that M that
yeah I think what I'm assuming why
recruitment owners love that is because
they like you just said that they
already had that data so like if they're
then generating revenue from from
existing data they had rather than
instantly people feeling like they need
to go and look for new candidates which
means the cost of finding that person is
going to be increased every time right
whether you're paying like credits for
CVS or whatever but if the first P the
first step is how can we engage our
existing database which we've already
paid for the data we have the data um
yeah exactly it's a no-brainer and the
thing is let's say face it you know
we're all recruiters out there and we
all hate admin right so we're not going
to do it but if if we get a benefit from
doing something if you post a job in Far
fish and you instantly get a match of
the suitable candidates you post an
advert and it creates it now with you
know chat GPT and Ai and then it
distributes it all out online socially
and everything else and you get
candidates instantly coming back you're
more likely to stay in the heart of the
business which is your CRM yeah for sure
so why don't we talk about then leading
up to investment like you said
absolutely you should be proud of
growing a business organically I think
yeah typically if you find yourself in a
room of SAS Founders you very quickly
going to heard the word investment
raising investment these types of things
um so when when did you first start to
like did you always feel like that was a
journey you wanted to go on like when
did you first never no that's why it
took me so long like I really wanted
just to do my own gig and I'd heard all
these sort of horrible stories about
Investors um and I just avoided it and
that's what probably fueled my I don't
need to do this I'll just do it my own
way as anybody that does know me I'm I'm
very stubborn so uh that that wasn't but
um I you know they had a
point and I think I got to the stage
where um I could see the space in the
marketplace you know um earlier on You
could argue who needs another CRM right
but we built our space we' built our
position it was a we bit like the David
and glias up against access and bullhorn
and we were getting Ro tracked
you know we were growing 20 30% on year
um which was you know really good growth
um and I think it's all about timing um
and I won't lie uh but you know vineri
getting taken off the market and going
to access well that was a really good
time for us so I suppose as a as an
entrepreneur as well you've got to look
at timing and when's right and when's
the space for that investment to really
come through and what and how you're
going to fill it and I really felt that
from a UK point of view still being a
majority shareholder and an independent
but fueled by um you know P um strategic
growth money um now's the time for us to
really stretch our our legs and go for
it so so that that was the main
difference the other difference was that
I could also see that you know i' I'm
proud that we've built a really good
culture I actually genuinely do think
that everybody enjoys working for us um
and that that's good but um we also need
to really sort of keep up with inflation
High net costs and and and everything
was getting more expensive so at that
point um that's a lot of strain you know
we're almost 70 people in the company
now and having that all on my just on my
shoulders um that was a lot you know so
coming out Co um and sort of looking at
how I'm going to take that Journey To
The Next Step as you said there's
various stages you go through in running
that business and I thought you know
what I really you know I've got another
10 years definitely in me I want to go
out with a bang so let's really go and
annoy some people
no I love that yeah is timing that's
interesting what you say about timing
and I think yeah I think kudos to you on
being really stubborn around being
bootstrapped and growing this
organically um I think what why don't
would you mind sharing just like leading
up to the investment cuz I know how
difficult that can be I guess just a
couple of
things what did you find most difficult
about going on that investment Journey
that maybe you surprised by there'll be
people listening here that might think
about investment or just probably
curious about it
um my experience with it was it
literally is a full-time job so I found
that really difficult like you're trying
to run your business and look at the
direct problems ahead of you while it's
also looking ahead and then you're then
speaking to investors you're talking
about like where the business is going
and you have to have that big picture
but what were some of the challenges
that you run into because obviously that
was the first time you were doing it
right when you started having these
investment conversations you did you
find has been challenging about it it's
all challenging and it is much more
challenging than you think and I'd heard
all the same stories so I re I recognize
everything you've just said um so I
think I've got to also sort of I suppose
declare here for all those reasons I
decided that I was going to partner up
so I actually went with dels and I think
that was the best thing I did was get
represented by one of those those types
of companies to go you know and probably
from being in a recruitment if you're a
candidate trying to get the best job
then I wanted the best best brand in
front to me presenting what does what
does that mean to do they actually help
you then be presented and I guess they
can leverage their Network they're a
very very expensive recruiter
representing us onto the market they
almost broked they did they broker the
whole deal so and they have obviously
access already to all the um the
Investments that you know you I I
actually am not not lying I sit here
every week and I get at least three um
investors from all the world trying to
invest in us again or try to get
interest with us so I just sort of Park
them say thanks very much much Park all
in a folder but I don't know who's good
or bad right and you know you are
playing in a global front you know we're
in 30 countries now Etc as well so you
have no idea which ones to go with and I
was I was scared to get get this wrong
you know this is one of the biggest
things that you're going to do and put
through the business um so I I felt so
they brokered it at that time I'm sure
they hated it because they worked with
me for a good year before I decided to
really hit the button um you know they
did it on a success only basis
so you know they were doing a huge
amount of work for us they got me ready
for Dulin they supported me through that
Dulin process they met and you know met
and um and really sort of assessed all
the investors they introduced me they
organized all the presented they came
with me in every single meeting giving
me feedback so as an entrepreneur I
actually felt as though I got a sort of
business school year of actually
developing in my own self and how I
would approach selling your biggest
asset set that you try to uh achieve so
it it cost a premium but oh my God
that's the other thing out there um you
know I'd heard it as well don't do Less
Than 3 million investment totally I
would almost say now don't do less than
five because how much did you raise so
it was Strategic investment of 4 million
um because you know your fees you know
you're you're taking around 600 off that
stra we yeah but I mean going through
that for the first time with your
experience up until then being this was
also a very big decision for you just
personally cuz you was like you never
was going to have a boss yeah exactly
you never it's an important one so like
I understand why you that yeah why you
ended up investing in that CU it sounded
like there there's there was so much
value there besides getting the end
outcome which is getting the right
people at the table and and signing the
deal yeah C curious then um just
interested myself if I'm honest like
what what ended up being like the most
valuable parts of the business that may
because I'm sure you went into those
initial conversations like this is
Firefish this is what we're great at
this is why it should be this multiple
this is what makes our business really
unique and valuable did any of those
yeah it's such a great question because
it is it's finding your hidden gems and
actually our hidden gems was our
marketing our our inbound marketing
stream we basically we we can scientif
we're very Data Business ourselves and
we can essentially for 10 years you know
we have been able to look at the
Strategic grow of our ratios in terms of
we know that one in every three 1 to 10
businesses that come are um that comes
into US converts within six weeks it's
that scientific so having that and being
able to prove that over the number of
years um was hugely valuable yeah I mean
that's going to give people confence
aren that's interesting so marketing was
there anything else was you was you
maybe surprised how much weight they put
on like your leadership team and how
like skilled they were I don't know is
there anything else that you maybe
surprised on like what where they
weighted a lot of value yeah so they do
and they definitely want to see a good
leadership team around you and I think
you know I probably that's what delayed
my decision to doing that is I wanted to
make sure that it wasn't the Wendy Show
which a lot of people out going yeah I
know um trust me that's not what my aim
is um it's just my faces out there a bit
um so I needed to make sure that you
know that team was actually presenting
so you know one of the things that do
were great with me and saying you know
don't come to all the presentations you
know get your team in front of them you
don't be in the door you know so that
you know that you're fronting it they're
happy and delighted with you but make
sure that they're happy with your team
um I think that also was h i was good
with that as well because this was not a
decision just for me though I'm still
majority shareholder this was a change
in the company that you know my guys
have been my my management team have
been with me some of them for over 10
years so this was a change to their you
know everyday life as well and I wanted
them to be really behind that decision
too so they had to feel right in the
investor we chose because you know at
the end of the day if you can get a
situation where you're in the driving
seat and you can choose the investor
then that's definitely the best place to
be yeah and then before we go into like
yeah what basically your vision is in
terms of like what this Strategic
investment is enable you guys to do just
a couple of things which again I think
people be interested in you're just
talking about it there but one
immediately where my um where I just
thinking when you're talking about that
experience was how did Wendy approach
internal coms around this did you keep
it fairly under wraps or like you said
obviously you wanted people to buy into
like why this is happening this isn't
just about Wendy getting to this moment
cuz I feel like
sometimes the perception can't isn't
necessarily true in terms of like some
people might thought Wendy's going to
get a huge payout oh my God she's going
to be absolutely buzzing like I don't
know like what was the how did you
approach the internal coms to make sure
people actually bought into what was
happening rather than going maybe
deciding oh what's going to happen to
Wendy now she's going to have this big
payout questions to like um yeah is is
fiveish going to change like is his
company in Glasgow is that massively
going to change now so like how did you
approach that so important as well um
you're pretty good at
this um so I'm all about transparency I
think everybody that joins my company is
like really surprised at how much I
share with them and I've actually also
done like three or if not four rounds of
employee share options as well so every
two to three years um we do um another
round so I specifically did another
round just before we went into this and
every year we have an annual shareholder
so I've got over 20 people in my company
so that's a third pretty much now that
are all part of that company and that
means that they're part of you know
whatever happens in the company going
forward so I think that's I believe in
that um hugely um so the shareholder we
have a shareholders meeting so all my
shareholders that was 20 of them were
absolutely fully aware of what was
happening and why we were going to do
this and they were behind saying yeah
let's do this we're we're good with
understanding that this could be our
time to really grow Beyond you know what
Wendy's done now yeah and you know they
can see that this will enhance their
career and their job security going
forward too um because as a company
grows there's more opportunities for
their careers so we did that um and then
we also um brought the rest of the
company in before the deal was done too
so they actually knew um and I took the
risk that um you know that could have
gotten out and that could have been Mis
misconstrued but um you know the company
is all about your people and they've got
to behind they're they're the journey
and they've got to be driving it from
within so you know it was not a surprise
to anybody they all knew about it they
just didn't know which one we would
select at the end fair enough and then
just a bit of um don't know I wouldn't
say it's a personal question but I'm not
interested in anyone in particular but I
feel like this could be interest would
be did you find the once I all got
announced and stuff did you then have to
run into a handle then people's
perceptions of like well I should be
paid more now then or like just this
perception of like you have all these
funds you know what I mean that's that
can be difficult totally yeah yeah said
about individuals but I'm sure that's
something that yeah like the perception
as an employee is like we've got all
this money now so like how much you
going to pay me exactly what's in it for
me and you're not wrong um but
interesting one of the questions I got
by the um the the main CEO of our of
foresight that we we went with um was so
you've got balls coming down here and
asking for all this money um tell me
this isn't just going to go and pay
salary reviews internally so I had that
question straight up before I accepted
the money um and I was honest with him
and I said well yeah if you want to
retain my staff you're going to have to
do some of it yes so um there's been a I
think we have been working well each of
our staff get two reviews annually so
it's not like an annual salary an two
reviews each year um so we were able to
do something for everybody but we have
been true to our value that we focus on
talent and talent shining through so the
the talent shining through have done
better um because those are the ones we
want to retain so that hasn't
changed and if there was a perception
that you know I can get more money
elsewhere and they're not part of the
journey fine rock on M yeah it's
interesting and then just final piece I
think more from the perspective of I
know you worked with deoe and they
probably helped with this a lot
but less interested in terms of like the
particular P firm that you partnered
with but just as a whole through that
whole um Journey like what is it that
you think were some of the core pillars
that you learned that what you aligned
with who could be like a good investor
or a good partner like what were some of
the things that you learned was like you
know what they tick this they definitely
showcase this to me what were some of
the things that you ended up uh yeah
really understanding that made you feel
confident and happy that these are the
right partner what what did you look for
exactly yeah so it came it it's quite up
to the 24 hours before I made the
decision I was going with another
investor really yes it was really
stressful um wow I know it's a storying
at half but probably have to do the did
you have to let them know or did Delight
that oh my God right so Delight did it
but but I'm not kidding cuz I felt
really bad about that cuz I wanted to
tell them but I signed an exclusivity
with foresight so I couldn't and Del
were like you cannot talk to them I was
at my my my daughter's swimming Gala um
and I I had from the CEO of the other
investors like 10 Miss calls really
three messages I'm like oh my God and
were like I couldn't speak to them and
delights were like I've had the same I
do not know I've never had this with
another company I was like well I'm very
flattered but um so yeah was it that was
hard I I subsequently obviously after
the exclusivity the deal was done I had
a good call with him and explained what
went is but one of the main reasons was
that and and foresight were not the
cheapest I will not do personally as
well with foresight but they were the
right the right fit for our company um
and it came down to they believed in the
team and they're going to let the team
do what they want they're going to
support us and push us to grow up and
move things and become a bigger business
that we needed to do so that sounds a
lot autonomy correct so it really I
didn't think it did I thought no I'm
ready and everything else but actually
the team pushed me for autonomy So I
listened to the team so that was one of
the that was one of the core pillars and
the other one was keeping the customer
at the heart of our business so some of
the things that started to get backed
down in terms of how they wanted to get
involved with maybe um looking
at we're very good at customer service
and I don't want to lose that m and I
just felt that we might lose our way
with some some of the things that were
coming up there as well well reducing
your cost on customer service support
and stuff yeah yeah that makes sense um
and I said that as the last thing but
just quickly I think again people might
be interested in this so obviously with'
all I understand why Al it would be
important especially when you've been on
that business Journey for so long like
yeah you want to still feel like if you
have an idea or a certain strategy that
you just believe in your heart is right
and then you have you have someone tell
you you can't do that that isn't why you
start your own business is it really
like I went out on my own you know 2003
I have not reported or have to justify
anything be difficult so but like what
what does the like now having that
investment and partner what does the
Cadence look like in the sense of like
do you have like a monthly board meeting
do you have a quarterly board meeting is
that what does that look like yeah so
that was quite interesting as well
because you go through quite a lot of
adjustments I'd say it definitely takes
six months months to bed in um so you
know we now have um an investor director
on our board they also H introduced us
to well they didn't introduce us I
recruited my own chair but they insisted
I had a new chair okay um who I'm really
pleased with Richard Le grown lots of
SAS businesses um Kai Murray and I um
who was our chair and um non-exec you
know brilliant in recruitment she'd run
search throughout um you know the UK but
probably after eight years of working
with one another we were too similar so
they wanted somebody to come in and
challenge me so that was fine but I had
to go and pick them so so that was a new
exact board and definitely formed that
so our original board because we did
have all of that has become much more of
an operational board so that's taken a
little bit of time and just also getting
used to the level of you know at some
point for at least one month my CFO and
I just felt all we were doing is board
papers that's an adjustment you know
it's like and I I struggle like I'm sure
many of your listeners would anything
you don't think is adding value to the
business you're like why am I doing this
but I understand the purpose so I'm
going with the process and then how and
then how far are we now from that event
happening is it i s watch your video
other day is it over 6 months it is yeah
so um it was just in April that we all
get it confirmed so you know that's s
six months then passed and and and
actually you know again if you're going
for investment best time to do it is
when you don't need money so you've got
real strategic growth plans that you
don't necessarily you're not scrapping
around correct so actually we really
only invested November and December and
started using the money um so all of
that has been really great foundations
of restructuring our product team um for
growth um so you know now I'm I'm I'm
starting this year super enthused you
know in terms of like I feel like it's
the new stage of our company now as well
hard work's been done by the teams uh
all last year to change adjust um and
now we're ready to to shift and what are
you then let's talk a bit about this
shift then like again um I did a post
about this recent recent I don't know
what you think about this I feel like
what what you have remained true to and
when I went through um the most
upto-date five fish again some of the
most common aha moments is around the
marketing piece and like the insights
you offer uh for the customers there and
the engagement you get and the things
you're talking about what I really the
way that I really like to think about
things my post was around
I don't know how useful it is to have
like predictions on like how things are
going to play out of course you should
really try and understand where things
are going and and make bets but actually
what you should really remain focused on
and double down on is like what isn't
going to change and this was totally
inspired by a podcast I listened to with
um Jeff Bezos where he was like what I'd
rather focus on yeah what isn't going to
change what isn't going to change for
Amazon it's being able to easily find
products um at a good cost delivery
times are low they're not do you know
what I mean so like what are some of the
things you said the shift there this
isn't about drastically now changing
fire fish and bring all these new things
like what are you really doubling down
on and remaining true to that you feel
like is going to be just as important
but you're going to do it better yeah
like towards the end of this year and
Beyond yeah so where we were as I said
was really on that web connection now
we're looking at that web as being one
of those connections to enhance the data
what we're doubling down on is that
utilization of the data in the core
product so we're looking at engagement
from web from LinkedIn from Source wh
from pag or from all of those other
sources were not locked down as much and
that's the integration part so what
we're doubling down now on is still how
you utilize and are much more effective
with that data because that data then
feeds AI that data feeds productive
analytics that data feuds what's do what
that that data will allow a business
become data d driven and understand what
they're doing is right or wrong now when
you get to um pushing our target market
size now which is now 20 to that 100
still business owners because I still
want to work with business owner um
entrepreneurs they need to know what's
working in their business they need to
know like what especially if they're
growing on that SC exactly and they
can't be especially in this market in
reminder of what's happened last year
they need to be really effective with
the money they're spending on their
their cost to acquire candidates their
time to hire all of those metrics and
that all comes down to the source of
putting that data in the heart of the
business and making sure that that's the
first place that really that recruiter
goes for it for the for their results or
for for the to answer questions that
they've gotten problems they've got for
their clients but what we're opening up
now is ways that that data gets enhanced
and and uh comes in it's not locked down
just from that one source through like
the Integrations and stuff like that but
still what you're remaining true to is
what likely isn't going to change from a
year from now and probably Beyond is um
if I'm a recruitment owner of a scaling
recruitment business am I get are we
maximizing the data that we already have
exactly and do we understand what's
working what isn't these types of things
yeah absolutely so that core problem as
well as you know a recruiter owner on
firef for should never miss a candidate
that is you know getting placed down the
road that you had the job on and you had
the candidate but they were more aware
of it yeah that's still going to be
important correct and that's never going
to go away do you still what about do
you view as part of that cuz I I don't
know if you'd like to view yourself as
Under the Umbrella of like a CRM but
just for to make it simple for everyone
to understand like I feel like the most
common sentence I always hear from
recruitment leaders is my team don't use
the CRM correct is that part of that
what you're remaining true to is exactly
that yeah is it by do by doing by having
that approach it should also mean it's
going to be easier for Wendy the
recruiter to to use the use your CRM use
the exactly that's one of our metrics
our customer success team look at is
utilization of that um of that system
through all their users there's no point
in buying a CRM if your guys aren't
using it right um so exactly that and
that's not just about forcing them you
know that's about reward you know that's
about giving them the purpose of why
they should come there first yeah and I
guess yeah if you have more and more
experiences of oh wow yeah I could have
missed that candidate or like those
types of the insights you are giving
them because the way that you're
approaching things that that makes sense
yeah what about the other thing that I
really liked when I saw it was the
analytics yeah talk to us a bit about
that how are you cuz I know that's
something that I was looking at your
some of the elements of like your
product road map um that got shared to
me analytics or something on there cuz
you've got you Tau me for it but I feel
like you've got elements like analytics
that um look really good uh Visual and
then there's bits that you want to
improve on this journey I feel like yeah
so we've been working um you know it's
everything like our competitors told us
maybe five times they were selling
against us five years ago saying our
analytics was rubbish right so we went I
went right I'll show them so I doubled
down on those analytics now we've got a
dedicated team to doing that and you
know effectively if other people are out
there you know it's like a cube 19 or
it's a powerbi straight on your
analytics that we don't charge any extra
for so from that point of view it
there's no point in having all this data
again coming back to make join the dots
for a recruiter allow them to easily
visualize anything in that recruiter so
they can start to see you know what
what's how many clients do they work
with that's in a sector how many
placements did they actually make within
those skill sets what should they do
more of because what was not working
it's amazing when you talk to a
recruiter and they and they basically
say I say well where did you where were
you successful last year I go well I
think I'm in I'm not sure and within 5
Seconds you can show them on I said this
is actually where you should be doing
more of because that's smarter you know
don't take that job on there because
that you don't have enough Supply and de
you know supply of candidates in there
you've got great Supply over there your
time to fill is this do more of that and
you can't do that without visually I
think recruiters are pretty visual yeah
for sure so you can't do that without
visually showing them so yeah the
analytics is really important and core
um cuz what bits do you already have
already because you already have these
elements yeah so so it's probably one
thing that I would say that our
customers are just waking up to and um
and they're getting to use more and more
so we've got um you know complete
versability and dashboards you can have
anything in there and you can make your
own cards it's real time reporting so as
soon as you do something you see it
there on the dashboards too um where
we're enhancing that is now um making
that easier to select in terms of what
cards you want to see and make I think I
think everybody likes data but it can be
noisy unless you really understand what
you want to see so we're helping them
almost by creating pre-build dashboards
and just making that very easy for them
just to copy over to get a sense of it
it's like what your job to fill ratios
are and like the important cause that so
get used to that first and then you can
enhance it and personalize it once you
get into the thoughts thought process of
that you can then give them the the sort
of Nory metrics that they should there
yeah obious that's going to become more
and more important for companies that
are on that scaling Journey because as
you would have experienced when you was
growing your recruitment business a lot
of these types of things you can
probably do by proximity when you're
like 10 15 20 people 20 people probably
hard but yeah then all of a sudden as
you grow you need to be way more
scientific around when you're hiring
what does you know ramping up how does
it take for our people to become
profitable these types of things that
becomes absolutely crucial exactly what
about marketing talk to us a bit about
that is there anything that you're
doubling down on there anything that so
that's probably yeah I think that's
probably a shift um for us in terms of
what we've been doing there is that we
will still go and look at that wed piece
to convert so if you're having events if
you're having um um you know any content
to convert that straight in but probably
we've seen the automation marketing um
best getting handled by some of our
partners um because they can and so
we've done a lot of Zap a work in there
as well so you can then go and select
from you know HubSpot you could go to
force 24 you could go to um Source Weare
again all of those ones because they're
really for they've been really sort of
dedicating that product uh Team into
that so it's probably one of the areas
that we are good with but
commercially I hate to say it but
recruiters owners are generally not as
marketing
focused so we need to sort of make that
we bit of a pivot and you know make sure
that uh we're really we're really
answering those questions that
recruiters are wanting within that
utilization of data now it might be you
might give me this a similar answer but
wanted to ask obviously when you started
this Jour Journey was very clear on that
web to see around the problem that you
wanted to solve solve as you're now like
you said timing you see an opportunity
you've got this strategic partner
investment you're investing a lot in
your product support and other elements
like what are some of the as you go more
up midm Market what are some of the like
core problems that maybe un team have
identified the frustrations that you're
really hoping more and more companies at
50 60 70 person heads going fire fish
helps to solve this problem what are the
things that your yeah we've naturally a
l large amount of our growth has
actually been through the constru uction
sector um and also um oil and gas
because we're off in Scotland um so
that's you know on our doorsteps a lot
so that's highly compliant right um
companies so we've actually been pushed
by our customer base to be pretty good
at compliance um and as a company grows
that becomes more important you know a 1
to 10 really doesn't care too much about
compliance maybe they they know that
they should but they don't have the
resources to have somebody in house to
actually manage that um and as you go to
that sort of 40 to 50 you've probably
got a compliance person that's their
responsibility of checking and
replacement making sure that candidates
are compliant and that's going far
beyond just GP um God I can't even
remember the name of it GPR GPD oh my
God you know what it is the data
permissions well we're so over that now
but that's going that's going Way Beyond
even that so so um we're pretty good at
that um compliance frustrations problems
definitely want to be known for yeah
exactly so I think you know that's a
surprise when people come to us as how
good we are at that anything else um and
in terms of uh I think we're really just
looking at how to segment um make more
use of those sort of lists um and be
able to visualize it in different way to
do more with it so um we will start to
at the end of the year start to move
that into more predicting as you said I
actually believe we can predict more
than than we think um AI is a big part
of it too we've um you know I did the
Expo last year and I talked about how we
were going to use AI throughout we've
done all of that so every piece of SEO
content blog recruiter summary job spec
we're all just analyzing that data and
summarizing for it that's pretty cool
now it's starting to think okay well how
can we do it on telephones um how can we
then sort of summarize meetings how can
we incorporate all of that make that
easier to then be fully searchable
structured data and you've also got I'm
sure um your customers going be really
interested by it but you also launching
this industry insights right yes I
that's like they like the but I found
that really interesting cuz I'm sure a
lot of recruitment owners are hear all
the time where especially if you just go
off what you see on LinkedIn everyone's
just talking about how great things are
yeah but if as a Firefish customer I can
see how we match up against our industry
peers in terms of performance I think
that's that's a really cool thing to be
able to offer to people yeah thanks it
was something that I thought you know
let's look at it in the last three years
you really can't sort of see what's
happening in the market so and as you
said some people are just going out it's
great but it's not really so that
concept of benchmarking um I think is
really cool so anonymously we take the
you know the the stats and the figures
and if they if a recruiter company opts
in they're going to be able to see what
their average recruit or how their
average recruiter is benchmarked against
another average recruiter within the
same sector it's pretty cool that is
that I really like that just because
again as you serving more of these
companies it's like you're just giving
them more data to make better decisions
and understand like yeah are we
performing at the levels we should be
exactly and we want to do more and more
of that as well so it's like you know
what's the average Source cost candidate
application the SAS metrics that I've
learned how to run a SAS business really
effectively we could learn an awful lot
from recruitment yeah for sure yeah love
that um well let's run out here then
where like obviously you said you're
going into this you're really excited uh
obviously yeah real pivotal moment for
you uh personally and for the business
and going through that Journey so where
would you you know what are some of the
things that you'd really like five fish
to be doing you know towards the end of
this year then what are some of the big
goals yes I think that you know we're
like this uh we're we're punching we're
punching now again right so I think you
know this time next year um I want to be
looking back on everybody now seeing us
as you know bigger player you know we're
on the table now every time I'm pitching
against um you know the bigger players
and we're winning so I want people to it
takes you know recruiters are a we bit
like macp and and I can say this cuz I'm
still one of them um in my head um but
you know it takes a little bit of time
to shift and a lot of recruiters still
owners still see us as um and our
competitors are still saying oh yeah
they're the we guys well no we're not
now you know we've we've got growth in
that Marketplace so this time next year
you know we're we're going to be
dominant in that that mid-market space
and that's really our aim while we still
look after our one to 10 1 to 20s really
really well love it well super excited
to be part of the journey I think kudos
to you on everything that you built so
far and um thanks for coming on the Pod
oh thanks so much and I'm really excited
about also you know working with you
love what you're doing too